on March 30th 2017 kendrick lamar
dropped his video for humble
it was a visual marvel in a sea of one
eye catching shot after another it was
this 10-second stretch from one 57 to
207 that people couldn't stop talking
about today you can see the seemingly
sporadic four precise movements in a
bunch of projects like dojo cats video
for Boozman kagu and Miguel's remind me
to forget angie rock and kendrick
lamar's Wow freestyle it suddenly seems
like hip-hop can't get enough of this
type of shot captured by this robotic
camera rig but there is a time when this
technology was mostly used for food
commercials to understand how the
Cinnabon went from food commercial
staple to avant-garde music video tool
we've got to rewind a few decades music
videos have been around since the 1950s
but at the stroke of midnight on August
1st 1981 a new era and music began MTV
the first ever 24-hour music video
channel aired for the first time it
played the Buggles video killed the
radio star as its first video
[Music]
labels began throwing money into
creating visual components to help boost
album sales and the music channel was a
perfect vessel for that and 15 years
after MTV's arrival there was a new
player in the video making arena
capitalizing on the music video boom
this is Jason row the managing director
of camera control who's been there since
the company's very beginning back in the
day all the big you know Britney Spears
Justin Timberlake all those big music
videos we worked on and they used motion
control rigs or cinemas to make it
happen though not exactly in the same
way one of the earliest video projects
to use a motion control camera system on
a big scale was a long long time ago
more specifically in the original 1977
Star Wars movie in early sci-fi films
planet and spaceship models would move
around the camera but digital effects
pioneer John Dykstra created a Dykstra
flex which allowed for the camera to
slowly move around the model this better
simulated movement while still keeping
the shot perfectly stable compared to
more modern motion control rigs like the
boat or the Cobra the Dykstra flex was
very large moved very slowly and it's
angle movement were limited despite its
limits in hindsight this new rig system
completely revolutionized video capture
it was one of the first times camera
movements could be programmed into and
albeit very large computer so they could
be precisely replicated take after take
this allowed editors to add in multiple
composites making arguably the most
iconic intergalactic battle scene of its
time from there this technology entered
more parts of the video industry from
commercials to smaller scale projects
like music videos enter camera control
which used the technology to create some
of the most iconic music videos of the
90s and early 2000s for the early
projects Jason says the motion
controlled movements were more statics
used mainly for super precise pans and
to create slow-motion effects like in
this Britney Spears video from 2000 we
used the slower larger rigs for motion
control but the faster rigs really
the last four or five years if it was
more long well I think a lot of the
previous stuff was was heavy post
effects heavy compositing and now I
think it's more about that dynamic
camera move you go from ground level to
high up in you know a second or less but
this advancement in music video
technology didn't come immediately at
the dawn of y2k the music video industry
faced its own mini apocalypse the whole
music industry was pretty much flipped
upside down physical media sales were
slowly becoming non-existent between
2001 2010 CD sales dropped nine point
eight billion dollars in revenue that's
because more consumer started getting
music online oftentimes illegally
through sites like LimeWire a lawsuit
brought against LimeWire alleged that
LimeWire alone costs record labels about
500 million dollars a month in sales and
that users stole about 3 billion songs
per month there were now new sort of
digital platforms for music so the
industry as a whole was very confused
and just trying to figure itself out and
reinvent itself at the time jason says
filming music videos back then was a lot
more expensive cinematographers were
shooting on film and productions needed
bigger crews to see projects through
with this loss of income from low record
sales labels just weren't investing in
videos too much the slump in the music
video industry really didn't affect us
because we are involved in many other
facets of the industry we do a lot of
feature film work a lot of commercial
work during the early 2000s camera
control shifted its shoots away from
music to feature films and commercials
using Cinna bots and food commercials
were and still are huge users of Cinna
bot technology we do a lot of what's
called tabletop shooting and one of the
main reasons why this technology is used
in that part of the industry is the
precise control that you have over the
camera
especially when you're shooting at very
high frame rates high frame rates are
used to prevent blur on fast-moving
subjects especially when you want to
create slow-motion effects but you need
a lot of stability to do it right
imagine you you're shooting at a
thousand frames a second and you're
trying to track something falling
through the air and splashing into a you
know a glass of water trying to do that
by hand would be super super difficult
meanwhile music videos were on the verge
of a comeback labels finally found ways
to comfortably capitalize on streaming
in the 2010s
with the help of the advertising
industry and subscription services as of
2018 streaming accounted for more than
75% of all music consumption and ad
revenue from streaming sites helped to
refill industry pockets at the same time
though YouTube a new platform was moving
past fun cat videos and babies biting
their siblings record companies were
finding new ways to capitalize on the
seemingly endless exposure that online
video had to offer and with new video
publishing technology came new video
capturing technology camera control
would soon be back in the music video
game music videos have come back in a
big way for financial reasons and for
technical reasons now you've got digital
camera systems that have become super
small less expensive to purchase less
expensive to rent and with less
expensive technology and fewer financial
restrictions video directors like Humble
director Dave Myers reached out to Jason
to push visual boundaries that call
would revolutionize not only Jace's
business but the hip-hop music video
Myers is crew attached smaller cameras
to cinah bots like the boat or cobra and
programmed them to move electronically
at super precise angles around a subject
the Sinha BOTS fast moving tracking
capability is the core of what makes
Humble so iconic after the video was
released the response was huge not only
to the video and the song but to the
camerawork after everyone sort of saw
that video you know we were getting
calls it a lot people referencing that
video for the type of movements that
they wanted to do and since that
watershed moment when Humble dropped
camera control has worked with artists
like ASAP rocky and post Malone and even
some outside of the hip-hop arena like
k-pop group onf when properly executed
filming with Sena BOTS offers surreal
larger-than-life
spectres cinematographers can control
speeds in the foreground and the
background of any given shot and because
the cameras programmed to make and
repeat precise movements editors have
multiple versions to play with after
filming ends it's this versatility that
makes the motion controlled rig so
desirable and why the technology will be
around for the long run
[Music]